hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play train
okay we're getting right in the thick of
it because the ominous music is thumping
away in the background over there so I
have no choice but to charge right in
well that's a little weird looks like
the shrooms I took earlier kicking in
holy hell it's pretty bad when the
entire train is warping around myself
don't know what to expect but I'm
guessing it's gonna be bad it seems to
be the general gist of what is that oh
that's a medical bag why is it medical
bags on that what happened something
just happened the whole train went Winky
wonky that's that good
I got a bad feeling about all this we
seem to be taking a journey through this
guy's life and I gotta say this guy has
led a weird life what was that I thought
I saw something okay there flowers and
knocked over crap all over the place and
then the train is kind of angling
upwards you know this part reminds me of
cry of fear because if you remember in
cry fear there was a scene with the
train after it fell off the mountain yet
to climb up it's dark in there why did
the thumpy thumpy stop I was just
getting used to it I was gonna low
myself to sleep okay this is strange
another flashback okay now now is the
best time you're going through your own
personal hell that's some pretty scenery
I gotta say this game has pretty
incredible graphics I mean there's a lot
of work put into it
I mean I'm pretty sure this is a
professional studio that made this game
it's really amazing and this is kind of
a jarring transition because I'm just
wandering in the back of my mind where
this is gonna go wrong because you know
that this can't sustain whenever things
get nice and oh yeah I'm going towards
the cemetery oh that would probably
explain it
yeah so from what I've pieced together
so far this guy has uh been in a
relationship with this lady is that's a
lady or is that a man so I can't quite
tell are you a man or a woman I still
can't tell okay anyway so I don't think
that's where we're supposed to be I
think we're supposed to be wandering
through these woods hello there's a bird
over there that's a lady that my lady
hello this field this field tearing you
to peace oh these feels the feel nothing
same with others look back and don't
correct nothing important okay well
alright then
ain't she pretty oh good oh I was good
it was getting too nice back there I was
waiting until I get back to my nice
homely train here and thank you the
thumpy thump is back
okay I just had this feeling that
something was behind me okay this is
getting kind of messed up here cuz I
don't think this is normal
I'm just gonna go ahead and say that
this is not normal man this is freaky it
was like the introduction to gray right
here is wonky alright then I'm gonna
have to call the train company and
complain because something is not going
right here I'm not in control hello
okay hey was that the Met is at the
Metro last light symbol that's the last
of us what the hell I have no idea
what's going on Oh aren't I handsome I'm
a handsome devil strange
so I get distracted by how handsome I
was in the rear view mirror and didn't
notice that car coming out of nowhere
alright then passenger get out of the
car
Oh who's that
Oh
I hear oh there's two fire I heard fire
it just didn't see fire yeah you might
want to get farther away drag him a bit
more just a little bit more no usually
in video games cars explode when they're
on fire all right then where am I now
okay oh good I was wondering things were
seeming a bit too normal there for a
second what the hell I'm having trouble
moving what the hell
hahahaha what the hell Jesus Christ man
oh my god this is messed up
I can barely move forward this this is
wonky oh my god is that chair coming
towards me or what get off the wall man
I don't know where we're going but we
gotta move ha ha oh man it's a bad acid
trip I'm walking like an epileptic squid
on LSD is crazy
the thing these lights are here to guide
me down this long hallway of nothingness
just keep stretch it out why come back
here what are you hiding from me what
are you hiding from me nothing a door at
the end of the hallway well this should
lead to happy fun times world of
sunshine and rainbows waiting for me I
thought of her son behind
okay that got me good but I don't have
those planned that way oh good
things have gone pastel what is am I am
I in purgatory or something this is this
is very strange this is very strange get
some sort of weird growth going on
around the edges
is that water why am I going into water
I'm not I have no damn idea
okay I've slowed down considerably I've
heard that there's only two save points
so I'm gonna assume that I gotta go to
the end of the game now it's not a long
game from what I've seen but man this is
trippy I gotta admit this is one of the
coolest horror games I've ever had the
chance to play is really cool I'm like
on the edge of my seat the entire time
it's just absolutely insane the
definition of insane
I mean games like cry fear and afraid of
monster have tried to portray like going
out of your mind but this game is just
absolutely perfect at it oh oh something
under the water
oh I'm we're just going down deeper
what the hell haha man okay
am I gonna drown now maybe that's what
happened like all this games like the
last gasp of a dying mind trying to claw
together reality after his train crashed
into the ocean I have no idea because
even the piecing together of the end of
the flashbacks it didn't entirely make
sense I mean it was some guy robbing a
store then meeting some lady in the war
all right then
okie-dokie the train is officially
opened up I think I'm I think this is me
leaving the Train what the hell I hear
some sort of otherworldly screaming
going on Wow
alright then okay is this where I dive
up to my death into the pit of
nothingness nothingness absolutely
absolutely I know I'm not in control
anymore you make the jump man anything
to get it oh hi wait no don't don't
follow the monkey don't follow the
leader don't be a lemming you're being a
lemming okay here we go whee well that
was fun
glad I get to fall to my doom like that
oh good and back out man that is a
pretty scene that is a really pretty
scene I mean usually on the unity engine
when you see indie games they're never
put together as well as this one is okay
I'm an old man now
hello pretty lady you're that lady from
the mannequin part don't think I don't
recognize you
now you're that kid from the mannequin
part I recognize all of you don't think
I don't what a nice nice day out
the sun is shining perfect day for a
ride straight into hell okay I have a
weird theory about this game but I'm not
gonna say it until the end yeah I know
that feeling bro don't know is this guy
gonna die do you have a heart attack
uh-oh he's going down keep me together
man you know one died just yet fun's
just about to start up nope he's gone
he's out of here
poor guy
and the heartbeat stops okay haha dia
maybe it's better that he died there cuz
then he gets to escape the hell of that
train what the hell okay now I have two
theories I have two separate theories
one is more extraordinary than the other
but you may like that one this is so
weird
so cool though I mean it's very
experimental game and that's what that's
what I really like about some of these
indie games they're really really really
varied in what they can do and and the
stories that they can tell them they
tell it in unique ways and and that's
never a bat well it's almost never a bad
thing when someone tries something
different I think that's the end if I'm
not mistaken
unless there's one more part oh hello
riding the rails oh is this a credit
sequence maybe haha ah alright then yep
that's the end okay Wow okay here's my
first serie that's probably not correct
this is my incorrect theory so don't
judge me on this one the train crashed
that's my theory the train crashed and
as you were travelling through the Train
you were playing as different people
being different people who in their
experiences in their last moment and
flashback through life that's the wrong
theory I know that's wrong because even
if I'm saying it it's wrong the correct
theory is probably you play as that old
guy who died just as he was getting on
the train and just as he was leaving and
just as he was leaving because he died
you got to flashback through his whole
life as his mind like as his firing off
its last neurons to flashback through
his entire life and just trying to piece
together what it can is the brain slowly
dies he travels through on the train as
his mind slowly fades and he travels
into death
you know what I mean that last jump
being the jump off the train like he's
leaving this world that's that's my more
correct theory of what happened there
may not be right it may not be but
that's just what I got I like my first
theory better he plays every was mooning
about their souls are trapped on the
train and they can't escape forever and
ever but either way that was a really
really really cool indie horror game I
loved it the sequences were spot-on
I only had one crash through it but you
know that happens in these indie games
it can happen they don't get to bug test
it thoroughly so I won't hold it against
him that was supremely well done you
know I haven't found the developer site
yet though so I gotta find it somehow I
gotta find it because this was so
unbelievably cool deserving a lot of
praise and so well put together this was
absolutely one of those one of the best
short horror games I've played in a long
time so happy that I played it so anyway
that's all for now
thank you all so much for watching if
you got more suggestions for cool games
like this be sure to send me an email
don't thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
oh hi Oh
so